greetings to my 3abn today family my
name is Ricky Carter and I'm going to be
your host welcome to another 3abn today
B
Q&A glad that you are with us we've got
another hour packed program with your
questions and we've got the answers
right here found in the word of God so I
hope that you'll be blessed I know I'm
looking forward to this program let me
introduce you to our panel to my right I
have sister Shelly Shelly Quinn welcome
sister oh it's wonderful to be here and
once again again we thank you so much
for your questions cuz you're part of
this program you're the reason we do
this program and it gives us it's fun to
study these these questions out and make
sure we're given the right answer amen
amen and next to her by a Skype we have
my brother Pastor James rafy welcome
brother good to be here Ricky and Shelly
always enjoy bible Q&A and learn a lot
as we delve into these questions it
helps us to grow in our knowledge of the
word of God Amen amen well I want to let
you know how you can participate with
3abn today Bible Q&A one of the three
ways you can do first way you can send
us your questions via email and you can
email us at bible QA
3abn.org 975 and then for those of you
who are on Instagram you can send us
your questions in that way at 3abn
official at 3 abnor official all right
well let's get started with the
questions Pastor James I've got your
first
question oh you know what before we even
actually go into the questions could you
lead us with a word of
prayer absolutely thank you sir Father
in Heaven just want to thank you for
this opportunity that we have to go into
your word that's a lamp to our feet and
a light to our path and we just love to
surround our hearts with the assurances
and promises and directives in your word
we pray that you'll be with us with the
listeners with those who've asked the
questions the holy spirit will be the
teacher and the answer and we pray in
Jesus name amen amen amen okay sir
here's your first
question if you have a child who is
lgbtq plus and has a partner that they
want to bring over for socializing
should we as Christians have them in our
home or even eat with them does the
Bible speak on this that's from Billy in
Washington who texted that to
us hi Billy and Washington thank you for
your question you know there are two
answers I'd like to give to this
question there may be more but from a
Biblical perspective and both of these
answers will come in the form of a
question so number one what did Jesus do
you know we used to wear those little
bracelets and that little used to be a
little frame that we always uh well got
popular for a while among many
Christians what would Jesus do and then
number two why would we treat some
Sinners differently than others right
now let's look first of all at Matthew
chapter 9: 10 and 11 it says there that
it came to pass as Jesus sat at meat in
the house behold many publicans and
sinners came and sat down with him and
his disciples and when the Pharisees saw
it they said to his disciples why did
your master eat with publicans and
sinners but when Jesus heard that he
said unto them they that be whole need
not a physician but they that are sick
but go ye and learn what that means I
will have mercy and not sacrifice for I
am not come to call the righteous but
Sinners to repentance and you know
there's a lot here in these verses in
Matthew Jesus Christ first of all is
telling us that the Pharisees the
religious people of his time the
Christians of his time the professor
followers of Christ as his time didn't
feel their need they were in need they
were Hypocrites and Jesus calls them out
in Matthew chapter 23 but they didn't
feel their need and therefore they felt
that they could judge Christ as he was
reaching out to minister to Sinners and
publicans publicans in his day were tax
collectors and they were the lowest of
the low and today of course we have our
categories of Sinners don't we and we
think that well you know it's okay to
hang out with a liar it's okay to hang
out with a thief it's okay to hang out
with someone who's maybe living in
adultery if your children were uh you
know Ma male and female but living in
adultery uh would you have the same
question and the answer many times is no
it's we put homosexuality in a special
category of sin and the Bible doesn't do
that in fact when you read Romans 1 it
very clearly identifies the sin of
homosexuality but it puts it in the
category of all sin you have people in
Romans chapter 1 that not only are
homosexual but are disobedient to
parents and gossips and man Stealers Etc
and then as it closes Romans Chapter 2
tells us and we'll just read these
verses together it
says uh therefore Thou Art inexcusable
oh man whosoever thou art that judgest
for wherein thou judgest another thou
Comm thou condemn thyself for thou that
judgest doest the same
things so Paul here is bringing all of
these sins to the Forefront and he's
basically saying that every single human
being is a sinner we're all guilty of
sin and even those who are Saints right
saved by grace are still the chief of
Sinners 1 Timothy chapter 1:5 and 16 so
we are not to judge others what is our
purpose then as Christians if we follow
the example of Jesus and the teaching of
the Bible we will treat all Sinners with
Grace and love as far as possible now
that doesn't mean that we are to endorse
or condone sin nor does it mean that we
should allow ourselves to be placed in a
position that compromises our Biblical
values but Christ ate with publicans and
sinners not to condone their lifestyle
but to reveal to them something of the
grace and the love of God to reveal to
them something better and the more we
follow Christ's example the more we
become Christlike the more we'll be able
to do that in different situations now
if you're going to have people over
their Sinners and you can't help but
judge them and criticize them and say
negative things maybe you're not ready
for that yet but God wants us to come to
a place where we can reveal his grace to
those who are in need of that Grace
without condemning and judging them
while at the same time maintaining the
standard of Christian righteousness
Purity Holiness and sanctification
Wonder amen amen I like that brother
thank you so much okay sister Shelly
here's your first
question in the days when Lambs were
were slaughtered and burned for the
forgiveness of sin I've never found
where women slaughtered a lamb for their
sins did the women have to confess their
sins to a man whether husband or father
and then the man called on the sins to
be forgiven by God I thought that the
only one that we confess our sins to was
to God directly and that was texted to
us from
Texas great question the Old Testament
sacrificial system that was instituted
by God revealed God's justice and his
Mery Mercy it was uh a pathway to
righteousness by faith in the coming
Messiah who would provide forgiveness of
sin and atonement for sin so what we had
were the general sacrifices for sin and
purification encompassed men women and
children there were personal sin
offerings typically the male head of the
household but it didn't
exclude women there was a daily offering
made morning and night by the priest the
day of atonement when the priest would
make a sacrifice for himself his family
and then for the entire community of
Israel God's system ensured that all
members regardless of gender all members
of the community were had access to
forgiveness amen now the cultural
context of Israel it was a patriarchal
society so quite often the men acted as
representatives for the family and
before the priesthood was set up we see
the men making sacrifices like in Job 1
15 we find that job regularly offered
the sacrifices for his family members in
case they had sinned after the
priesthood men typically brought the
sacrifices but the men even though they
may have slit the throat they didn't
offer the sacrifices only the priesthood
did that women were not excluded and I
want to show you that in Leviticus 12
6-8 we see women are encouraged to bring
personal offerings for sin and
purification Leviticus
12 verse six when the days for
purification are fulfilled whether for a
son or daughter she shall bring to the
priest a lamb of the first year as a
burnt offering and a young pigeon or a
turtle dove as a sin offering to the
door of the Tabernacle of meeting then
he the priest shall offer it before the
Lord and make atonement for her in 1
Samuel 1 and verses 24- 28 we see
Hannah is making a vow before the Lord
she made a vow before the Lord and she
brings an offering to the temple
sacrifices of atonement and Thanksgiving
for Samuel
1:24 when she'd weaned Samuel she took
up with she took him up with her with
three bows one eff of flour and a skin
of wine and brought him to the house of
the Lord in Shiloh and then it says in
verse
25 they slaughtered the bull so the
priest performed the sacrifices
interceding on behalf of the individuals
and the community but male and female
could bring the sin offering by the way
the priesthood was exclusively male
because they were the ones acting as
mediators and they represented Christ as
our only meteor so let me give you the
conclusion
Christ death on the cross ended this
sacrificial system right Hebrews 9:28
says he was offered once to Bear the
sins of many amen Hebrews 7:25 says now
he is our high priest and it says he is
therefore able to save to the uttermost
those that come to God through him since
he always makes intercession for them so
we see this Jesus is lifted up he
everything about the Old Testament
sacrificial system represented Jesus and
his Mist Ministry in 1 Timothy
25-6 it says there is one God one
mediator between God and man the man
Christ Jesus who gave himself a ransom
for all to be testified in due time so
he is our only mediator in first John 1
19 promises if we confess our sins he is
faithful and just to forgive us our sins
and to cleanse us of all unrighteousness
amen so you're right we only confess to
Jesus amen thank you excellent answer
amen amen all right Pastor James here's
your second question what is the best
gift to give God when we worship him and
that's from Andrew
great question Andrew I don't know what
the best gift is but I'll just give it a
shot and tell you what I think the Bible
teaches could be a really cool gift or a
great gift uh to give to God number one
a humble attitude when we come to
worship God we should have a humble
attitude God really appreciates that you
know God is close to those Psalm 138
verse6 says who have a humble or Meek
attitude but he's the proud he sees from
a far off and the reason I share this is
because you remember the story if you're
biblically uh literate or have studied
the Bible in Luke 17 it talks about two
people who went down to the to the
temple to pray one was a Pharisee and
the other was a Publican and the
Pharisee prayed thus with himself I
thank you that I'm you know a Pharisee
I'm an Israelite I'm pay tithe I I fast
uh you know I'm not like this man over
there and of course the Publican tax
collector bowed his head and said Lord
be merciful to him to me a sinner and he
went down to his house Justified and
what we see in this picture is that
humility is number one when we come to
worship God but the other thing that I
really think is important when we come
to worship God is praise and a
surrendered heart and thankfulness let's
just read a few scriptures on this the
first one is found in Psalm 51 15-1 17
this is David's attitude after he was
confessing his sin uh to God with Beba
and his adulterous relationship with Rea
best he says open Lord my lips and my
mouth shall show forth thy praise for
thou desirest not sacrifice else I would
give it thou Delight us not in bird
offerings the sacrifice of God or a
broken Spirit there's our humility again
a broken and a contrite heart oh God
thou will not despise so what's one of
the best gifts we can give to God when
we come to worship him a humble broken
contrite surrendered heart all right
Psalm 100 says Make a Joyful Noise unto
the Lord all ye land serve the Lord with
gladness come into His presence with
singing know that the Lord he is God it
is he that has made us and not we
ourselves we are his people the Sheep of
his pasture enter into his gates with
Thanksgiving and into his courts with
praise be thankful unto him bless his
name for the Lord is good his Mercy is
Everlasting his truth endures for all
generations we need more of that in our
worship service we need to trans
transition our worship service from uh
funerals to a time of rejoicing and
praise and thanksgiving for all that God
has given to us Psalm 107 asks these
questions and makes these statements I
love Psalm 107 we're going to look at
verses 1 and 2 21 and 22 31 and 32 this
is what it says oh give thanks unto the
Lord for he is good for his Mercy
endures forever let the redeemed of the
Lord say so whom he hath redeemed from
the hand of the enemy oh that men would
praise the Lord for his goodness for his
wonderful Works to the children of men
and let them sacrifice the sacrifices of
Thanksgiving amen and declare his works
with rejoicing oh that men would praise
the Lord for his goodness and for his
wonderful Works to the children of men
why let them exalt him also in the
congregation of the people and praise
him in the Assembly of the
elders I tell people one of the best
ways that we can do evangelism as
Christians is to praise God in his
Sanctuary when we come together in
Church Fellowship if we would praise the
God praise God and respond with firm
amens to the reading of his word not to
the clever stories or or funny
illustrations the pastor gives you can
pass them by but when the word is is is
spoken when the word comes forth with
God's promises and and the powerful
truths of the Plan of Salvation if we
can say amen and praise God that's one
of the best gifts we can give to God
when we come to worship him but it's
also one of the best ways that we can
actually do evangelism because when
people visit our church and they see
that we're alive and that we love the
Lord and we're praising him like there's
something going on here and I want a
part of it am so praise to God God
surrendered heart Thanksgiving for His
abundant mercy and Grace those are the
best gifts we can give to God amen amen
thank you for that beautiful answer all
right sister shelle here's your second
question how do we understand serious
mental illness like
schizophrenia are they biochemical
disorders or are they
demonic SL spiritual I was texted to us
okay mental disorders are complex I I
mean they are multifaceted causes some
are natural causes some are Supernatural
causes we cannot deny contemporary
medical research and the evidence that
shows that certain mental disorders or
conditions they're diagnosable they're
treatable there's abnormalities of brain
activity or perhaps chemical imbalances
say of the serotonin and the dopamine
like in schizophrenia or depression
Society genetics can play a part and
environmental factors can impact mental
health if somebody is living in a
climate that it's there's no sunshine
all winter long or there's toxins in the
home or pollution in the air the living
conditions social abuse these can also
affect mentally what is the solution for
these lifestyle therapy Diet Water
sunshine red trust in God counseling if
if you get Christian counseling for
cognit treat cognitive and behavioral
patterns also there's prescriptions for
mood stabilizers
anti-depressants and antipsychotics but
now let's look at the Bible and what the
Bible says amen not all ailments in the
Bible are described as being demonic and
we want to be careful about that but
there are some that are attributed to
demon possession in scripture now not
all those who were possessed by the
devil lost their mental and physical uh
faculties think about Judas Judas
sitting at the feet of Jesus I mean
Jesus had washed his feet the last
supper and Judas had so sold himself to
the pattern of behavior that followed
Satan that it says Satan entered his
heart that's in John
13:27 but he kept his mental faculties
but the inspiration of scripture reveals
that evil spirits can affect someone in
a physical or mental uh with a nervous
disorder Mark 9:14 through 29 we find
the case of a demon possessed boy and it
strikingly resembles an epileptic SE
teach scripture sometimes describes
demonic influence similar to mental
disorders that has bodily manifestations
like distorted countenance shrieking
body mutilation glaring eyes nashing
teeth they're foaming at the mouth and
convulsions Mark 5 1-15 is the account
of a demon-possessed man in the region
of the gines he lived among the tombs he
exhibited violent self-destructive
behavior and Jesus cast out the demons I
want to show you this was definitely
demonic Jesus spoke to the demons as
demons the demons responded as demons
and here is the thing in the case of
demonic possession when the demons are
cast out the restoration of physical and
mental equilibrium
is instantly restored so here's what I
want to say all Christians are subject
to harassment and
oppression by demonic spirits I mean
he's come to Ste kill and destroy but
we've got first John 4:4 greater is he
who's in me than he who's in the world
if you're filled with the Holy Spirit
you cannot be possessed by an evil
spirit you can be harassed however and
people the degree of demonic
control varies on your degree of your
surrender to Satan's will you can become
a slave of corruption you can open the
door to demonic possession through
occult sin like witchcraft or books on
spells or the Ouija board or fortune
telling and seances or through exposure
to Unholy things like a sexual sin or
some horror movies or dark music
and even objects of idolatry so what's
the prevention and solution here Romans
12:2 do not be conformed to this world
but be transformed by the renewing of
your mind and James 1:21 it says lay
aside all filthiness and overflow of
weakness receive with meekness the
implanted word which is able to save
your souls and of course Jesus said in
Luke
119-13 ask and keep on asking seek and
keep keep on seeking knocking keep on
knocking and the Lord will give you
we're asking for the Holy Spirit many
can be oppressed by demons few are
possessed but it's very real especially
when you get into areas where there's a
lot of Witchcraft the potential
spiritual issues require prayer and
discernment and they need to be
addressed by spiritual intervention and
pastoral care amen amen thank you sister
great answer amen all right Pastor James
I've got your third
question why is the Angel of the Lord
sometimes capitalized and other times
lowercase and that's from Linda in
California thank you for your question
Linda in California we find the word
Angel capitalized in a number of Old
Testament verses like genesis 48:16 for
example or Exodus 23:20 and 23
and even in the new King James version
it's an ex exception to let's say the
King James version Exodus 3:2 also
capitalizes the word angel now there are
at least two reasons why the word Angel
is capitalized in some versions of the
Bible reason number one the meaning of
the word itself we're going to look at
the Hebrew for the Old Testament meaning
of the word itself and then number two
the use of the word in the context of
the text that is under consideration how
the word is used in the context of the
text also tells us why the word would be
capitalized referring to God that's why
it's capitalized because it's going to
be referring to Divinity and not to a
created angel so first let's look at the
meaning of the word Angel Hebrew 4397
that's the Hebrew number in the Hebrew
dictionary for the word you look it up
in your strongs concordance and you're
going to find the word means to dispatch
comma a messenger comma specifically of
God comma an angel now when we look at
this definition we want to recognize
that many times we think that the word
Angel automatically means that it is a
created being but there are times when
this refers to a messenger of God and
there are times in the Bible when we see
that it is God himself who is coming as
a messenger we see this again and again
in the Old Testament and in the New
Testament God self appears to different
individuals let's just take a look and
we know this by the use of the word so
for example Exodus 3: 1-5 remember in
verse three in the new King James the
word Angel is capitalized now let's look
at the context and see if we can pick up
why now Moses kept the flock of Jethro's
father-in-law verse one the priest of
Midian and he led the flock of uh on to
the backside of the desert and came to
the Mountain of God even to Horeb and
the angel of the Lord capital a
in the new King James version the angel
of the Lord appeared unto him in a flame
of fire out of the midst of the Bush and
he looked and behold the bush burned
with fire and the Bush was not consumed
and Moses said I'm going to turn aside
and see this great sight why the bush is
burnt but it is not consumed and when
the Lord saw that he turned aside to see
God called unto him out of the midst of
the Bush and said Moses Moses and he
said here I am and he said draw not nigh
hither but put off thy shoes from thy
feet for the place where on thou
standest is Holy Ground and what makes
that ground holy God's presence amen
moreover he said I am the god of thy
father the god of Abraham the god of
Isaac the god of Jacob and Moses hit his
face for he was afraid to look upon God
so the reason why we see the angel
capitalized here is because it's
actually referring to God himself God is
coming down to speak to Moses God is
coming as a messenger if you will now
that doesn't make God created God can
show show up in a burning bush he can
show up as a as a dove you know as he
did with the Holy Spirit he can show up
as a man as he did in the person of
Jesus Christ he's still God God can show
up any way he wants and that does not
destroy his divinity or make him less
than God or create it Exodus 23 20 and
23 says behold I send an angel before
thee to keep thee in thy way and to
bring thee into the place which I
prepared for you now these verses uh are
speaking about the Wilderness wanderings
of God's people and again God says in
these verses that his name would be in
this Angel and then when you go to 1
Corinthians chap 10: 1-4 we're told that
the angel that went with them that
followed them that kept them watch over
watched over them was Christ that's 1
Corinthians chapter 10 uh verses 1-4 and
of course we know Christ is God he is
the Son of God he is divine uh not
created no beginning no ending Eternal
so we see both from the Hebrew meaning
of the word Angel as well as from the
context text of the scriptures that
there are times in the Bible when the
word Angel is actually referring to the
Creator God and not a created being and
at these times the word Angel is going
to be capitalized amen amen very good
answer thank you sir all right sister
Shelly I've got your third question yes
could you please explain what Jesus
meant in Matthew 8:22 and Luke 9 verse
60 where it reads follow me and let the
dead bury their dead but go thou and
preach the kingdom of God that's from
Audra in Georgia who texted that to us
audre I remember when this used to
confuse me as a younger person let me
read again Matthew 821
and22 it says then another of his
disciples says this man is a believer in
Christ he is a disciple to Jesus and he
comes to the Lord and he says Lord let
me first go and bury my father' but
Jesus said to himf follow me and let the
dead bury their own dead Jesus is
speaking figuratively here of the dead
he's saying let those who are
spiritually dead bury those who
literally die in other words this man
had faith in Jesus he'd accepted Christ
as his savior he's now different than
the dead he's made spiritually alive
Ephesians 2
4-5 says this God who is rich in Mercy
because of his great love with which he
loved us even when we were dead in
transgressions made us alive together
with Christ by Grace you have been saved
so this disciple of Jesus had accepted
him he was no longer longer spiritually
dead but most likely when he said Lord
let me go bury my father his father was
most likely still alive and this man was
delaying the action of commitment he was
saying hey you know I'm going to
procrastinate put this off let me stick
around till my father passes and he was
putting off the responsibility of
discipleship
so in essence he was asking
for to wait for an indefinite period of
time and what Jesus is doing he doesn't
want him to wait till his father passes
way to start serving him he says let
those who are spiritually dead bury the
dead and he's encouraging him take
action now we get this same same
encouragement we are to commit to action
as soon as we accept the Lord seek first
the kingdom of God in Luke 9
60-62 once again Jesus said to him let
the dead bury their own own dead but you
go and preach the kingdom of God amen
amen thank you sister amen amen all
right
Pastor James here's your fourth
question should children be baptized
before the age of 12 that's from Anthony
in Canada who texted that to
us H that's a good question you know no
no one child or adult should be baptized
that does not really fully understand
what baptism is all about and of course
no one should be forced to be baptized
at all you know baptizing little babies
uh who have no clue what's going on is
not really in the scripture now that
doesn't mean that a young person under
the age of 12 cannot be baptized and and
all children regardless of age should be
dedicated to the Lord from their
earliest years and that's what we do
that's what happened to Christ when he
was a baby he was dedicated to the Lord
and that's really what the Bible teaches
in in instead of the idea of baptizing
little babies so baptism is not so much
an issue of age as it is a commitment to
God with understanding of what that
commitment means
and so we look at some verses here in
the Bible let's for example go to
Matthew 28: 19 and 20 these are the key
verses regarding baptism it's the gospel
commission Jesus gave this to his
disciples and each one of us and he said
go ye therefore and teach All Nations
baptizing them in the name of the father
and the Son and the Holy Ghost teaching
them to observe all things whatsoever
I've have commanded you and lo I'm with
you always even to the end of the world
amen so notice here that baptism is in
conjunction with teaching teaching and
uh instructing those who are going to be
baptized to observe all things so you
have this teaching you have this
instruction and you have this action
people who are baptized are baptized
because they understand what the Bible
teaches they understand the gospel of
Salvation in Jesus Christ and they are
ready to observe those teachings that
Christ has given to us and see this
brought out even more clearly in the
context of Romans chapter 6 Romans
chapter 6 are always the verses I read
whenever I'm baptizing people these are
my go-to verses because this is uh the
epitome of what baptism looks like in
our Christian experience know you not
Paul says that so many of us that were
baptized into Jesus Christ were baptized
into his death therefore we are buried
with him in baptism under death that
like as Christ was raised up from the
dead by the glory of the father even so
we also should walk in newness of life
for if we have been planted together in
the likeness of his death we shall also
be in the likeness of his resurrection
knowing this that our old man is
crucified with him that the body of sin
might be destroyed that henceforth we
should not serve sin so baptism is about
a death to self it's dying to our old
man to our old nature and it's being
resurrected into a new life in Jesus
Christ that's why when we baptize people
we put them down into the water we don't
sprinkle them they go all the way down
into the water completely covered their
whole body their whole face everything
is covered and if we were if I were to
leave them there as the person who's
doing the baptism if I were to leave
them there for let's say five or 10 or
15 minutes guess what would happen they
would die because they wouldn't have any
Oxygen they wouldn't be able to breathe
but we lift them back out of the water
so this there's this idea of dying to
self in Jesus Christ and then being
resurrected into newness of life we died
our old ways and we're resurrected in
Jesus Christ to live a new life for him
so once we're taught to observe all
things that God has commanded us once we
understand that baptism is a death to
self and this world and a resurrection
to a new life in Jesus Christ once we
are mature enough to make a decision to
live for God and to die to self then
we're ready for baptism at whatever age
we are amen amen answer thank you sir
very good answer very all right sister
shelle I've got your final question okay
is Mary Magdalene the same Mary of
Martha and Lazarus prove it from the
Bible please that's from May in Georgia
who texted to us oh May what a challenge
but let's go Mary of magdala or Mary
Magdalene is mentioned as a devout
follower of Christ we find in Mark and
Luke they both mentioned that she was
healed from Seven demons or evil spirits
now all four gods gospels Place her at
the cross Matthew and Mark say she
observed where Jesus died and where his
body was laid all four gospels bring
show her at the tomb on Sunday morning
Mark and John says that she was the
first person the resurrected Christ
appeared to that's Mary of Magdalene our
Mar of magdala now the the Bible
mentions three incidents with Mary of
Bethany she's also a devout follower of
Christ she was the sister of Lazarus and
Martha she was the one who sat at his
feet to learn we find that in Luke she
was present at the death and
resurrection of her brother find that in
John she's
identified as the one who anoint OED
Jesus feet let's look at that John 11
veres 1 and 2 it says a certain man was
sick Lazarus of Bethany the town of Mary
and her sister Martha it was Mary this
is John 11:2 it was that Mary Mary of
Bethany who anointed the Lord with
fragrant oil and wiped his feet with her
hair whose brother Lazarus was sick now
let's back up this I don't want to
confuse you but watch how everything is
interwoven all four gospels tell the
story of a woman anointing Jesus this
what happened at a supper or Feast we
find it in Matthew 26 Mark 14 Luke 7 and
John 12 where where is this Feast taking
place in Bethany at the house of Simon a
Pharisee Matthew Mark and John explains
it happens in
Bethany Matthew Mark and Luke identify
it as Simon's house only John doesn't
mention Simon by name when did it happen
it's the final week before Judas
betrayed Jesus Matthew Mark and John
identify it as the final week where
people get confused is Luke did not
always write his gospel in chronological
order so Luke's seems to appear like it
happened at a different time but watch
it's too intertwined it's the same event
in all four gospels so how did it happen
Matthew Mark and Luke mentioned the
alabaster flask Matthew says it was very
costly for Egan oil Mark said very
costly oil of spikenard Luke talks about
this same
Alabaster uh flask says it was fragrant
oil John doesn't mention the alabaster
flax but he describes it as a pound of
very costly oil of Spiker all right
Matthew says that she pours it over his
head and body Mark says she pours it
over his head Luke says she anoints his
feet and wipes him with her hair which
is the same thing that John says that
she anoints his feet and wipes him with
her hair so who is this Matthew and Mark
just it's an unnamed woman Luke it's an
unnamed woman that he identifies as a
sinner and Mary understand during
Matthew Mark and Luke Mary was very
likely alive she was a disciple of
Christ she wasn't named John wrote
several decades later only John
describes and gives her name that it was
Mary of Bethany so here's
interesting Matthew Mark and
John Jesus is quoted saying the same
thing why do you trouble this woman the
poor will you'll always have with me but
me you do not have or always have with
you but me you do not have always she's
done a good thing a good work for me she
did it for my burial Matthew and Mark
both repeat this phrase of Jesus
assuredly I say to you wherever this
gospel is preached in the whole world
what this woman has done will also be
told as a memorial to her I think that's
why we see it in all four gospels
there's four accounts of this anointing
the woman identified as a sinner in Luke
John introduces as the Mary of Bethany
so here's what's reasonable to
assume
Mary of Bethany Martha's sister Lazarus
sister moved away at her youth to
magdala and became known as Mary of
Magdalene and this is someone who then
came to know the Lord who became a
devout disciple moves back to Bethany
now she's Mary of Bethany but in respect
for her they don't name Matthew Mark and
Luke don't name her it was probably
after she died that John wrote his
gospel and named it that makes really
good make sense thank you very much
sister for that amen yeah great all
right Pastor James I've got your final
question okay I find that in the recent
past Pastors in our country have been
urging us not to preach the prophecy of
Daniel and Revelation in Evangelistic
campaigns the reason is the prophecy
scare non-adventist and they say the
prophecies attack Sunday Keepers most of
us join the SDA church because of the
clarity of the Bible that we got by
studying prophecy won't this make our
church just like any other church if the
message is in the Bible as the present
truth are these pastors being led by the
Holy Spirit to refuse to refuse prophecy
education if this should be the case do
we need to share any more books such as
the great hope the great controversy
when God said remember Etc which dwelled
greatly on Daniel Revelation to
non-adventist
loaded question great question I love
this question I just want to remind our
viewers that there are always two
extremes to be avoided in anything that
we do that's religious Isaiah 30:21 says
you'll hear a voice behind you saying
Walky this is the way Walky in it when
you turn to the left or when you turn to
the right so considering these two
extremes what we're experiencing with
the pastors who don't want to teach
Bible prophecy because they scare people
or attack people is one extreme and then
the The Other Extreme is you know always
harping on Bible prophecy denouncing
other churches uh scaring people with
these images and and pushing on them all
of the the Doom and Gloom and end time
prophetic events to try to force people
to make a decision for Jesus Christ and
between those two extremes we find
balance and that balance is found in the
Bible itself right when you look at the
word of God you see very good reasons
why we should be preaching Bible
prophecy now reason number one The Book
of Revelation is entitled the re reation
of Jesus Christ it's not the revelation
of the Antichrist it's not the
revelation of the seven last plagues
it's not the revelation of the Dragon in
fact the Antichrist and the dragon
aren't found until you get into
Revelation chapters 12 and 13 that's
halfway through the book the first half
of the Book of Revelation is all about
Jesus amen the whole focus of these
prophecies is about Jesus Jesus in the
candlesticks that's his Incarnation
Jesus the lamb slain in the midst of the
throne that's his crucifixion Jesus
mediating before the golden altar with
our prayers and his Merit his incense
that's his uh intercession in heaven
you've got the Incarnation the death uh
crucifixion and the the mediation of
Jesus Christ in the first half of the
book the whole book is about Jesus in
fact we're told that there's a three
full blessing pronounced upon the Book
of Revelation you don't find that
pronouncement on any other book of the
Bible why did God do that he did it for
the very issue that we're looking at
right now because people would
misunderstand The Book of Revelation the
book of Revelation was not given to
scare us it was given to prepare us Amen
to show us what's coming around the
corner you know Amos 3:7 says surely the
Lord God will do nothing but he Reveals
His secret unto his servants the
prophets so Bible prophecy is given so
that we can see around the corner so we
can know what's happening so we can be
prepared not scared amen now the whole
emphasis here according to John 14:29 is
Jesus I Jesus says in verse 29 of John
14 and now I've told you before it comes
to pass that when it has come to pass
you might believe and of course we're
going to believe Bible prophecy once it
comes to pass but Jesus was using Bible
prophecy to get us to another
destination not just to believe the
prophecies a lot of people believe the
prophecies but they don't necessarily
believe in Jesus a lot of people believe
and understand for example about the
mark of the beast but they don't
necessarily trust Christ as their
personal Savior and so in John chapter
13 in verse 19 the Bible says and Jesus
is speaking here I speak not of you all
I know who I have chosen but that the
scriptures may be fulfilled he that eats
bread with me has lifted up his heel
against me now I tell you before it
comes that when it comes to pass you
might believe that I am he amen that I
am he right so Bible prophecy is given
to help us in the trials ahead and the
troubles ahead to believe that Jesus is
the Messiah now it's interesting that
this verse is is spoken in the context
of Judas Judas is the one that Jesus is
talking about in this context of Bible
prophecy and prediction he's predicting
that Judas Judas is going to betray him
and Judas is called the son of predition
there's only one other power in the
Bible that's called the son of predition
and that power is identified as the
Antichrist power in second Corinthians
or Excuse Me 2 Thessalonians chapter 2
so what God is doing here in John
chapter 13 and in 2 Thessalonians and in
the Book of Revelation and the Book of
Daniel is he's helping us to understand
what we're up against in the end of time
now some years ago in the 1990s I went
to Pakistan to do some evangelism and I
met a pastor there a Pentecostal Pastor
who was ah head of 120 churches he had
come to the seminar that we were doing
in the daytime and then we were having
an afternoon session for pastors only on
Daniel and Revelation and he was really
intrigued with the approach that we had
to the Book of Revelation it was all
about about Jesus he was the center of
Revelation so he asked me to come back
the next year in 1998 and preach to his
Pastors in lore Pakistan so I went back
uh God's leading and there were over 300
pastors there not just his Pentecostal
pastors 120 pastors but there were
pastors from the church of Pakistan
there was a Catholic priest there there
were missionaries there the hall was
full and we began to share on the books
of Daniel revelation we didn't get
finished so I went back the next year
1999 to finish the series and eventually
ezek Zer Ro got invited to 3abn Danny
Shelton I don't know if you've heard of
him but he heard all about Ezekiel and
he wanted to have him interviewed and so
he came to 3abn and Danny was on the set
with me and Ezekiel and the conference
president from uh retired from Pakistan
and we were talking about these meetings
and Dany as he does asked the question
that would have made anyone feel
uncomfortable he said to Ezekiel who by
the way his whole church was praying
that he wouldn't become an Adventist he
said he asked pastor Ezekiel R he said
why would a Pentecost to invite an
Adventist preacher like James raffy to
come over there and preach to him Daniel
Revelation and I thought oh no here we
go what's he gonna say he put him on the
spot as Danny is able to do so often and
so I thought I prayed about I thought I
hope he you know I hope he doesn't feel
uh uncomfortable answering this question
and Ezekiel didn't feel uncomfortable in
the least bit and here was his answer
the reason why we had James come over
and preach is because when I heard him
speaking in p on the Book of Revelation
he he was making Christ the center and I
know that all of my pastors are scared
to death of the Book of Revelation they
don't even read it and when I heard him
making Christ the center I said my
pastors have to hear this and so I
invited him so my pastors could hear
Christ in the Book of Revelation and
they would begin to understand and study
the Book of Revelation for themselves
that is the opportunity that we have so
it's sad that some pastors feel like you
know we can't present these books
because they're full of Doom and Gloom
and scare people but that's not the
purpose of these books
and maybe we as Adventists have
misrepresented these books and not put
Jesus in the center and we want to put
Jesus back into the books of Daniel
revelation we want to make it the
revelation of Jesus Christ not the
revelation of the Antichrist amen amen
that is the whole thing is it's got to
be Christ centered to bring people to
him amen amen exactly exactly amen well
I hope you've been blessed by this I
know that I have I want to remind you
how you can participate with your
questions in this program you can do
that one of three ways you can send us
an email to Bible QA
3abn.org on social media like um
Instagram specifically you can send us
your questions that way at
3abn official at 3abn official and also
have you heard about our website 3abn
Bible anwers.com that's an excellent
website where you can get a lot of your
Bible questions answered we've got
questions on there from topics on what
happens when you die topics on divorce
the Antichrist the Sabbath and plenty
other topics you can get all those
questions answered right there at 3abn
bible anwers.com so check out that
website when you can well we're going to
take a short break to let you know how
you can participate with 3abn you'll see
the information on your screen so don't
go away we'll be right back
amen if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible
Q&A then tell your friends each Monday
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at bible QA
[Music]
3abn.org 8 228
3975 be sure to include your name and
where you live and then watch the reaban
Bible Q&A for answers from God's word
thanks for coming back let's get some
final thoughts from our panel sister
Shell I was just thinking about the
question about the mental disorder
whether they are uh natural or
Supernatural I just have to tell you my
mother when I was 15 was hospitalized
and diagnosed as manic pressive which is
bipolar is what we call it today it's
interesting they it took a year for this
diagnosis bless her heart she was
institutionalized for a year as soon as
a doctor showed up who knew what was
going on he gave her a lithium salt and
that's what her body was missing she was
in her right mind in about 12 days and
came home now this is interesting
because she was made to feel like
taking a
medication for bipolar mood disorder was
a sin and I told her mama if you were a
diabetic your body would be lacking
insulin it's no different there's
sometimes there are chemical imbalances
and God has blessed us with medical
science to know how to treat them so
don't put that on that stigma on someone
to make them feel like like it is a
psychotic break from a demonic
possession amen Pastor James your final
thoughts so really Bible prophecy is not
meant to scare us but to prepare us and
you've got to love this about Christ and
about his word I want to encourage our
viewers you can actually see this done
in a series that we do at 3n called
salvation and symbols and signs go to
3abn website look up salvation symbols
and signs and you'll see how Christ is
the center of all the Prophecies of
Daniel and Revelation amen amen amen
thank you for that well with time has
come to a close I want to leave you
though with this fun scripture song that
you can claim in case you ever in fear
for God has not given us a spirit a
spirit of fear but of power and of love
and of a sound mind second Timothy 1
verse 7 memorize scripture it'll do you
one ERS thanks for joining us we'll see
you next time God bless
[Music]